r chaque année 200000 familles déclarent
être victime de violence conjugale
pourtant le taux de plainte quelle que
soit la violence est très faible elle
n'est seulement que de 10 % un problème
que les spécialistes souhaitent résoudre
la violence fait peur elle tétanise il y
a un phénomène de sidération et du coup
ce qui
entraîne une une difficulté pour pour
parler pour et c'est notre devoir
d'aider à la libération de la parole
pour pouvoir repositionner la loi
et ce combat contre les violences
familiales est une priorité dans
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yveline il
est même inscrit dans le contrat
2015-2020 de la ville le but aider les
familles et communiquer sur les
organismes qui peuvent leur venir en
aide aujourd'hui l'agglomération reste
sur ces missions d'animation de
coordination faire connaître les
ressources du territoire auprès des
professionnels auprès du grand
public aujourd'hui c'est ça la ce sont
les principales missions de de
l'agglomération une trentaine
d'intervenants et environ 120 personnes
ont participé à l'événement plusieurs
colloques seront organisés tout au long
de l'année bonjour